السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي ان الولايات المتحده لا تتوقع
حدوث اي تقدم في الاتفاق النووي الايراني
في المستقبل واكد كير بين الاتفاق النوويه
مع ايران ليس محطه تركيز بلاده الان
من جهته قال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف انه التقى مع وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد الله
الاردن وسط تدهور العلاقات بين ايران
والاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك على هامشي مؤتمر
بغداد المنعقد في البحر الميت واشرب ابو
ريان الى انه اتفق مع عبد الله على ضروره
قنوات التواصل مفتوحه
واستعاده الاتفاق النووي على اساسي
مفاوضاتهم الجنه
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيين بلاده
ستدعم احياء الاتفاق النووي طالما تم
احترام خطوطها الحمراء وبانها مستعده
للخطوه النهائيه ليبرم الارتفاع واكد عبد
الاحيان خلال مشاركته في مؤتمر بغداد على
ضروره ابتعاد الاطراف الاخرى عن تاسيس
الملف
نقلت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه عن مصادر
انه من المتوقع ان يزور الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي نزل في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
اليوم الاربعاء في اول جوله خارجيه له منذ
بدء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ومن المتوقع
خطابا امام الكونغرس مساء اليوم
القوات الاوكرانيه باستهدافي مقاط عاتيني
حدوديتين هما بيل جورود وبيانسكو داخل
الاراضي الروسيه من جاده قال الرئيس
الروسي
تتعرض مره اخرى للتحدي واقر بصعوبه
الروس يظهرون امثله استثنائيه عن الشجاعه
خلال القتال في اوكرانيا بحسبه
في تونس
برئيس الحركه
ورئيس الحكومه الاسبق علي العريض فيما
تعرف بقضيه التسفير وقالت الحركه وان هدف
الاعتقال هو التغطيه على مسمته الفشل في
الانتخابات بدورها اعتبرت جبهه الخلاصه
المعارضه ان الاجراء ان يفتقر للاسس
القانونيه من جهته انتقد الرئيس التونسيه
التركيز على ضعف نسبه المشاركه في
الاقتراع للتشكيكه البرلمان بينما بعد
اتحاد الشغل للحوار للخروج من الازمه
بدوره دعا متحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ستيفاندوج ريكا سلطات التونسيه
الى ضمان احترام حقوقي رئيس الحكومه
التونسيه السابق علي العريض بما في ذلك ما
يتعلق بالاجراءات القانونيه
من الجزيره
[موسيقى]